there's a loop I'm out of it I don't
know anything about children ah I
currently don't have any plans to have
children
anytime remotely soon I'm thinking maybe
when I'm like 50 my wife and I
definitely want kids maybe sometimes two
and a half I want two and a half so you
can have half a one slightly smaller
child I'm just trying to take care of my
plants right now I'm not doing a very
good job what is the estimated annual
cost of having a single five-year-old
child sixteen thousand two hundred ten
twenty two thousand three hundred and
seventy four thirty thousand 106 who you
got to get their hair cut
also yeah like shots and look five girls
shouldn't be drinking I'm going a on
this see a lot of money
hey yes sixteen thousand dollars I can't
afford a 28 year-old man if they're this
cheap like ten minutes from now I might
be like cool I'm gonna get out there and
have five kids according to the USDA
United States Department of Agriculture
the average percent of household
expenditures attributable to one child
is fifteen percent twenty percent twenty
seven percent divided by fifteen my gut
has been wrong both times so far but I'm
gonna go with it again taxi that's
roughly twenty percent twenty two
percent twenty seven this is rigged
I mean out freaking hard question what
is the rest of that money go to it's
like car payments and car payments fish
tanks like adult fish tanks what is the
largest total expenditure on a child in
a two children family health care child
care slash education housing like
anytime I see a kid I just don't
approach them because they're usually
like sneezing or caught like they do
that kid coffee or their Alex B has
never done me wrong except at the
beginning so I'm sticking with you see
housing yes whoo what kind of house
people living in okay you just stack the
kids like Legos I'm taking away your
kids but what is the estimated total
cost of raising a child up to 18
including all of 17 without college
expenses two hundred and forty five
thousand three hundred and sixteen
thousand five hundred and thirty-four
three hundred and seventy two thousand
eight hundred and twelve dollars first
of all I just want to say all three of
these numbers make me ill 112 tie a +
quarter of a million dollars it costs a
quarter of a million dollars to raise
your child to the age of 80 no one goes
up there to once it hold on hold on okay
- forty-five thousand is a two hundred
forty-five oh yeah you get some really
nice shoes for two hundred and forty
five thousand dollars good maybe two
parents either gone a lot of vacations
or you don't go on vacation stick around
the home have a bunch of little use
running around they'll grow up tell the
world about you I think I'm still
leaning towards vacation okay I'm
surprised it is really expensive it's a
decision that you can't take lightly no
matter what stage of the process you're
in thanks mom
thanks man a hella Ferrari